This is Inside Politics
with Bernard
Shaw and Judy Woodruff in Washington.
That was June 7th.
1993 Judy Woodruff's
first day in the anchor
chair of Inside Politics.
She along with our late
former colleague Bernard Shaw,
made Inside Politics must see TV
for knowing
what is happening
on the campaign trail and beyond.
And guess what?
I'm honored to have Judy here with me
today on my first day in this
in this chair.
Judy, of course, works for the PBS
NewsHour now.
So good to have you here.
And I am so happy to be here.
I'm having
kind of an out of body experience
right now.
I have to be honest.
All these memories come flooding back
many memories.
What did you learn
covering politics on the show
for so long?
I think the thing that I learned
and of course,
it was a very different era. Oh, yeah.
We were just saying that
was 30 years ago.
Was it politics can be civil,
that it matters a lot
and that it affects every person
in this country.
It's not something that's just we
we spent a lot of time
talking about
what personalities are up to
and who said what about whom.
But in the end,
it affects the American people.
And I think for me, that was the
that was the biggest takeaway.
Okay.
Well, let's actually show our viewers
some of the flavor
of what you're talking about.
I want to take you on a trip down
memory lane, Judy Woodruff
from some of your shows in the nineties
It's the name that has spent more money
than anyone has spent in Iowa
in a Republican caucus race.
At the 1980 convention,
I was working for
another television network at that time
and it was such a great story
to be working on
whether Ronald Reagan was going to pick
former President Gerald Ford.
If you add up what he got
in terms of a vote
and what you got
and he asked you to get out of the race,
he might have been the winner.
What would you say to Bob Dole?
There may not be a war room per se,
but White House
officials certainly seem in
full battle mode
now.
The hairstyles, which
were awesome, I'd say
they were very open up here and very I'm
glad you're always on trend.
But it did it did feel different.
Are you optimistic
that American can get even
maybe not back to that,
but closer to that?
Oh, I am.
I mean,
as I think
I suggested a minute ago, Dana,
we are in a very
we're in a tough moment right now.
In American politics.
There's just
a lot of mudslinging happening
and people are angry.
But, in fact,
you know, people
the two political parties
were at each other's throats
and but it was just much more civil.
I mean, I remember covering
Bob Dole
and then Harry Reid
going at each other than Harry.
Harry Reid called
President George
W Bush a loser
and then apologized for it.
It was it was just a different
a different tone at the time.
Yeah.
I was thinking you're saying Bob Dole
I was is
stop lying about my record
when he said that to George H.W.
Bush. Right.
And it was a huge deal it was.
But there were actually
politicians apologizing
about what they had said.
So we learned a lot
and we covered big stories.
We covered everything from
nine 11, which, of course,
you know, consume what we
were doing at this network
for four months.
The Gingrich revolution
you remember that in 19
we thought that was as crazy
as it was going to get.
I want to ask you, if I may.
You're working on a project now at PBS
where you're going out
and talking to voters
and trying to find out if America can get
across that divide.
And I'm finding that it's a work
in progress.
You're right.
I'm spending these next two years
with the News Hour PBS,
traveling around the country,
interviewing voters and experts about
why we're so divided.
Where did that come from?
And I'm finding it's remarkable
in a place
like Oklahoma,
where 100 years ago
they had a terrible race massacre.
They're still having debates over
how to teach the history of race
in the schools.
It's it's
a it's a great education and it's a
it's a work in progress.
I'm always optimistic.
Dan, I know you you know that
But but and at this point,
I have confidence
that the American people, Judy,
are going to do the right.
It is really such an honor
that you're here.
Thank you for taking
so proud
to return
Back to CNN desk assistant to anchor.
So proud of you.
Thank you.
Thanks, Judy.
And I also want to remember
Bernard Shaw, who passed away
nine months ago.
He was a journalist, journalist.
He led the way in being a good person,
both on and off the air.
We're really we really do miss him.
I also want to thank John King
for reviving the story
Inside Politics
brand about a decade ago,
building it back to a show
where viewers can get information
from the best in the business.
Thanks for joining Inside Politics.